well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages
so in the next half hour or so we will
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist
carol malone and the political editor of
the liverpool echo liam thorpe lovely to
see both of you
lots to discuss as well today so let's
uh
crack on and take a look at the front
pages the times first of all
says the race is on to stop the spread
of the indian
covid variant as part of those efforts
the daily mirror says there will be a
jabs blitz in variant hit areas
in a bid to save the summer the
financial times leads with former prime
minister david cameron's appearance
before two parliamentary committees
during which he denied
any wrongdoing in his lobbying
activities on behalf of the collapsed
firm greenfield capital
the metro picking up on the revelation
that mr cameron used his boss
lex greensell's private plane to fly to
his second home in cornwall their
headline
sleazy jet the former prime minister's
reputation
is in tatters says the guardian with a
second story
on a revolt against immigration
authorities
the telegraph has a story on the
aftermath of the pandemic saying
patients
will be able to see their gp face to
face after
an official climb down the sun says
prince harry has attacked his father
for passing his pain on and that he
won't do the same
while the daily mail condemns the prince
for appearing to criticize the parenting
techniques of prince charles and the
queen
so lots to discuss as i said carol
malone and liam thorpe are here
liam let's go to the daily mirror first
of all shall we jabs blitz to save
summer
just in the last half hour new measures
announced
by the government um what is the plan to
hit this uh this variant then obviously
this is
a deep concern you know regarding the
spread of the indian variant and
actually we've got some
locally uh local issues in merseyside
the area of formby and septum has seen
really rapid rise in cases after the
indian variant
was identified here and obviously bolton
is a big issue and we're hearing now
tonight that there's going to be
a rapid response team sent to bolton
inform being incepting we've got surge
testing taking place
but the government is coming under more
and more pressure now to to do the thing
that it has done best in this
process the government made a lot of
mistakes but vaccines has been
where the success has been so there is
growing pressure for the government now
to roll out
you know some surge vaccine to be like
them and
speed up those second doses people who
need them the most and really start to
vaccinate
younger people in the areas where we're
seeing the rapid rise of this indian
variant
i think when we looked at the different
variants that we've had we haven't quite
had one
that has been as much of a concern as
the indian variant
and it is the one that is really going
to cause a potential problem in terms of
reopening the country
yes and liam just to clarify then
earlier we heard from blackburn with
darwin suggesting that some
down to 18 year olds could get the jab
and also in other places
uh the idea that second vaccines will be
brought forward too
to try and give maximum immunity if you
like is that what you're hearing
yeah that's the thing because obviously
we know that vaccines protect people but
from what we've seen from the evidence
as well they also are good at stopping
transmission
so we're now seeing um that the
likelihood in those areas places like
blackburn and bolton that we will see
that kind of absurd vaccine and i think
that the government will be looking at
potentially rolling that out to other
areas as well
such as you know for the in merseyside
because
vaccines are the way out of this and
vaccines are hopefully
as far as we know at this point are
still capable of dealing with the indian
spain
and i suppose carol the main point about
this is tackling the other variants of
concern
the south african variant the brazil
variant happened in lockdown
the timing of this as the time says
couldn't be worse with the
you know opening of hospitality proper
uh come monday
well you see that but there is still no
evidence
that any of these variants cause much
more serious illness so you know we i
think what we haven't got a plan
yes cases are doubling but that has not
been reflected in deaths
the question is will the vaccines that
we've had
deal with the variance and when i say
deal with
i mean will they stop them from killing
people
and if the answer is yes to that well
we're just we're going to have to deal
with it you know
we've got to we've got to stop talking
about curved infections like every
infection
equals the death because it doesn't
anymore and it's it never
did but it certainly doesn't now and i
think all talk of lockdown
i don't think people are gonna weather
or wear another lockdown i mean you just
look at social media today people are
saying well not doing it again
you know boris is saying he's anxious
because sage
the the scientists are saying they're
anxious but the thing is they're always
anxious to scientists that's their job
it's boris's job to decide the best
thing to do for the country what they're
doing in the north in blackburn and
bolton
and by by getting you know increasing
the vaccine program and speeding it up
is a great thing to do but you know if
if we know
if we know that the vaccines stop this
this virus from killing us then
then surely we've got to treat it like
any other virus like a flu virus
yeah we might be over a few days but if
it doesn't kill us let's get on with our
life
let's open up the country again you know
there have been predictions from the
bank of england
that that our economy is going to go
into overdrive
we can't stop that now we mustn't stop
that man
well obviously still many age ranges
have not been vaccinated
and i suppose that the fear comes from
seeing the you know the burning pyres in
india the bodies washing down the ganges
being caught
yeah but the vaccine hasn't been given
on the on the same kind of
level as it has here you know in this
country 82 percent of the clinically
vulnerable
have been vaccinated 90 of all nh staff
have been vaccinated now we're making
plans to vaccinate the over 18. you know
that's
that's the bet that's as much as we can
do really but the indian doctors are
reporting that younger and younger
peoples
i know they've got oxygen shortages
there younger and younger people are
being affected so
you do want to protect all members of
society even here in the uk
yeah there are some concerns there are
some concerns in india it's still being
looked at that people who have been
vaccinated
are still getting ill with the indian
strain i think the problem is i sort of
agree with carol on one point and
disagree on the other
one is we can't we still can't really
compare this to the flu because we don't
know anyone
and near enough about it and these are
new strains so we need to be able to
report it but what i would say is
you know i saw andy burnham saying today
you know talk of regional lockdowns it
just
it just didn't work and you know we know
really well in liverpool for example
when we were put into
tier two and other places were in higher
tiers people just went between the two
and it
it didn't really it wasn't properly
policed it didn't have any impact
actually
it made things worth it because people
kind of came here from higher tiers so
the talk of regional lockdowns is
difficult i think most people would
agree
ramping up vaccinations to all people of
all ages in those difficult
areas that are experiencing problems
it's got to be the way forward
well i think what go on camera i'm just
gonna say i think where questions have
to be asked us
you know this we knew this india verb
was here there are three strains
in this country the latest one being the
most dangerous we think
but you know we've got to ask why yet
again the government only made
in only put india on the red list on
april the 23rd
we saw what was happening in february
this first came here in february
we knew what was happening in india in
february why didn't we stop travel
to and from india you know we we've made
the same mistake this time as we made at
the start of the last lap
lockdown we've allowed free travel to
and from a country
where this virus is raging it just
doesn't make any sense
yeah well i mean we know that boris
johnson canceled the trip to india and
the decision was taken very soon
afterwards we've got the g7 coming how
many of those nations will
will go on the green list just before
those g7 leaders come i mean there are
there are political decisions being
taken here aren't there liam which we
need to look out for
there are political decisions being
taken but i totally agree with carol and
it's
somebody described the government's
handling of kirby watching like a very
slow car crash because
we just see the same things happening
again they seem to be kind of trying to
snatch
uh snatched victory from the jaws of
defeat or whichever way around i mean
because every time that you think things
start to go the right way they they act
too slowly and
and you know we saw we saw what was
happening in india there were there were
repeated calls for them to make that
decision
personally from my perspective you know
things have been going quite well in
this country i think
most people would would be happy to to
stop most international travel and think
look let's just
try and enjoy a summer here in this
country but the government seems to kind
of want to
do everything at once um and and it's
not going to work because when these
variants are still
in you know in operation in other
countries it's too dangerous
but you know it's another mistake in the
government as far as i'm concerned well
as we heard uh this week one third of
new mothers in this country
were actually born themselves abroad
they'll want to visit family members
that's part of the reason people want to
travel there's lots to consider and
let's leave that for now see what else
comes out
of of the idea of surge testing and the
extra measures that has just been
announced by the government uh but moved
to the ft
uh david cameron suggesting what does a
young prime minister do
if he wants to get stuck into to help a
company and he was doing it for the
greater good during the pandemic and how
do you think he performed carol
david cameron described today as a very
painful day for him and it was
it might have been painful for him it
was excruciating to watch and to listen
to him
today i mean he was savaged by by that
committee that treasury committee quite
rightly
uh he was accused of demeaning himself
he was accused of what's happening his
way
around whitehall on the back of a
fraudulent
enterprise a lady called siobhan
mcdonough who's labour
she also accused him of painting lex
greensil
as the reincarnation of the late mother
teresa
she also called on him to admit that his
lobbying for the nhs
wasn't for the health of the nhs but
also the health of green seals balance
sheets
so yes he's taking a dropping quite
rightly but you know the legacy of green
sill
won't be about cameron and his
opportunism or his greed or whatever you
want to call it
but it will be the damage this company
has wreaked
around the world and questions have to
be asked here
at this inquiry it's not just about
savage in cameron we have to ask
why greensville was allowed to make
loans
of tens of billions of pounds in full
view
of the uk regulator of the bank of
england of the fca
and and no one blew the whistle on this
no one did a damn thing to stop it
you know people and businesses were
losing money all around the world
and the company in which that sorry the
country in which this company was based
the uk didn't do a damn thing to stop it
so yes while
it might be sport for the left to have a
go
at cameron it also has to be to find out
why it wasn't greensville wasn't stopped
before yeah sorry to rush you just want
to very quickly get to the metro
sleazy jet this idea that he hopped on
private planes asked the question you
know
where did you who did you tell about
this in terms of tax just very quickly
on
on the sort of detail of it then liam
yeah and i mean just just i completely
agree with carol
is it was cringeworthy stuff and you
know what the
the message picked up on he couldn't
remember how many times he had hopped on
the left screen till jet to
get back to his three million pound home
in in cornwall and
there was some some remarkable uh quotes
from cameron today there was one
where he said a heart-wrenching moment
where he said that there should just be
more
guidance for former prime ministers who
who don't just want to be on the board
of some big bank
or make the old speech around the world
and i think that really you know is is
going to get to the heart of the matter
you know the tiny violins are going to
be out for those poor former prime
ministers who don't just want some
job on a big bank it was a cringe-worthy
performance it was excruciating
i thought angela eagles summed up the
the lobbying well and she said it was
more like stalking than lobbying
and i thought it was particularly
amusing when david cameron had to
explain why he signed up
all his texts with love dc uh he said
that his
his kids said that he shouldn't be
signing up text at all and i tend to
agree
yeah well uh he said lessons learnt
email and uh and writing in future for
former prime minister
had some defense of some of the points
you made as well but uh plenty more on
that no doubt at half eleven more to
come
tonight though prince harry appears to
criticize his father and grandmother's
parenting styles
discussing that after this break
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now carol malone
and liam thought welcome back to both of
you
prince harry making the front pages
again carol to explain
i got the mayor's headline is how low
can he go
and and actually it's a question that we
we are now all asking ourselves
he's just done an interview with
something called the arm-chair expert
it's a podcast
and it's some kind of la celebrity
called dax shepherd
and in it he is slating the parenting
skills
of the queen and prince philip just
weeks after he was there burying his
grandfather
he's actually he's talking about
breaking the genetic
link he said he moved to l.a to break
the genetic link because he's saying
that his father
treated him the way he was treated
so you know he's having a go at the
queen and prince philip while the queen
is mourning her husband she buried
herself just a few weeks ago
and he's still giving these interviews
he's now making a career he's earning a
living
out of trashing his family and it's a
terrible sight you know he said he
doesn't want his kids
to grow up with the same kind of
parenting as he had what kind of example
are his kids going to have when he's
forever dumping on his family and
criticizing them all
it makes him look far worse i think than
they are he really
needs to stop this now and find another
way
of earning money other than dumping on
his family you know
to be talking about the parenting skills
of the queen
at this moment in time is actually about
as low
as you can go and somebody sorry you've
gotta go out of time
no that's quite right i know um liam you
wanted to talk about the front page of
the guardian as well which is
uh netanyahu suggesting that riots in
israel are bigger
threat now than gaza but we know that
there are
multiple israeli airstrikes currently in
the northern gaza strip
the gaza ministry of health now says 109
people have been killed
that's including 28 children perhaps we
can talk about that next hour when we
see you at half 11.
liam carol thank you